bonjour les téléspectateurs fidèles pour ceux qui viennent de
nous rejoindre, c'est moi le méga mien,
maître de tous les méchants jusqu'à ce que je réalise que
mon destin était d'être un super-héros, le méga
esprit est de retour, je suis un gros problème et de
rien, vous l'êtes tous  chanceux de
m'avoir comme héros wow tu
menaçais la ville il y a quelques jours maintenant
tu la défends je veux être un
combattant du crime tout comme toi tu es adorable d'une
manière touffue voici un souvenir
c'est soit un papier  poids ou une
grenade flash, alors faites attention à ça de
Dreamworks Animation the Doom Syndicate
Je les méprise plus que les
cols boutonnés, ok, méga esprit, c'est que de toute façon
d'accueillir votre ancien équipage, vous pensez toujours que
je suis un méchant, faisons un bon
crime à l'ancienne.  fête ou
amusons-nous avant de nous lancer dans des
affaires maléfiques, personne n'agit comme un
méchant jusqu'à ce que je puisse les arrêter, nous devons
maintenir les apparences maléfiques, c'est assez
sournois, pensez comme un héros, ces
passants sont sur le point de se faire écraser, cela
n'a pas l'air bon pour  eux oh c'est vrai, je suis
un héros maintenant il est temps de donner un coup de pied à un butin condamné du
Syndicate
oh je suppose que c'était une
grenade flash Mega mine contre le Doom
Syndicate le nouveau film et si vous aimez
Megamind autant que lui, c'est l'une de
mes choses préférées dans  le
monde entier continue de s'amuser avec Mega Mind
règne sur la nouvelle
série